il est convaincu que vu de l'espace le
la terre ça ressemble à sol le dcti
pointe et des petites lèvres donner à
comprendre les choses vont que les
frontières de l'espace que tu les vois
là yves jacques bonjour bonjour sa fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas eu de nouvelles
on vous dit en france au québec un peu
partout tu en est il vraiment le malheur
c'est d'avoir dit je pars en france à
faire tout le monde a pensé que c'était
pour toujours
alors que ça fait 25 ans que je fais des
allers-retours sait pas puisque pas plus
difficile que d'aller à son chalet le
week-end en fait c'est peut-être juste
un petit peu plus long donc voilà
j'habite sur le plateau mont royal
depuis 25 ans vous allez faire en
quelque sorte votre retour sur scène à
l'automne 2008 dans une pièce intitulée
je suis mi cuit mais ce que je comprends
pas c'est que vous jouez à séoul où
jouer un peu partout dans le monde
et là vous allez à la petite licorne
c'est sans aucun doute pas pour l'argent
alors n'annonce pas pour l'argent c'est
pour le fun c'est pour le plaisir de me
coller à des nouvelles énergies des
nouveaux talents et j'ai vu le travail
de mathieu quesnel
en fait on a fait une lecture pour pour
tout vous raconter et dans la salle ce
soir avaient tous les jeunes qui
travaillent en ce moment qu'il n'a
encouragé mathieu qui m'ont re découvert
je peux dire ou sinon découvert il
m'avait jamais vu jouer sur scène ils
savaient pas que je chantais il savait
pas et ça a été pour moi c'est comme un
reborn
oui bon acteur si je peux ça a été très
séduisant pour moi de vivre ça
[Musique]
vous avez incarné à quelques replis des
personnages qui se questionnaient
justement sur leur sexualité je pense au
déclin de l'empiré américain personnage
de claude et vous avez dit c'est ce
personnage qui m'a aidé à farming
communiante assumer mon orientation
sexuelle
explications explication c'est que enfin
je pouvais laisser à liste que je
cachais en fait depuis des années que je
me cachais ce qui faisait que j'étais un
drôle d'acteurs ou en direct les choses
par s'est pas offert à mon goût à moi et
à partir de là je pouvais exprimer les
sentiments de quelqu'un qui avait les
mêmes que moi en fait donc ça c'était
pour moi c'est une libération
et c'est ce qui m'a poussé plus tard
aussi à faire un coming out au grand
public en fait ça m'a aidé à vivre aussi
parce que justement ce les amis qui
suivent plus bas ce n'est plus mon
problème cesser ces mots c'est leur
problème
et les gens qui ont des difficultés que
cela aussi et voilà donc je suis
quelqu'un de plus libre et en plus libre
je suis un meilleur acteur parce que je
suis beaucoup plus connectés avec ce que
je suis
[Musique]
je veux parler de la face cachée de la
lune de robert lepage que vous allez
présenter justement ici au théâtre
jean-duceppe mais en mai 2019
vous avez incarné pour la première fois
le personnage central le seul personnage
en 2001 avec le temps je me dis que
c'est une pièce qui vous habite ok
complètement à tel point que maintenant
je pourrais l'improvisé vous savez
krombach lui improvise quand il fait ses
créations et moi il a fallu que
j'apprenne tout ça est rare est un gars
brillant
sinon génial je pense qu'il pense qu'on
est tous un peu comme lui avec on
comprend tout de suite les choses mais
oui oui c'est vraiment une seconde
nature maintenant et c'est très zen pour
moi de jouer ça c'est l'impression que
je plonge pendant deux heures dans un
espèce d'univers qui est un qui est
devenu le mien mais qui était surtout
celui de robin un cosmonaute si
quelqu'un d'inspirer un astronaute
quelqu'un de très bien financier pendant
de la ville de québec de robert lepage
il construit son nouveau théâtre le
théâtre diamant à l'endroit même où vous
avez tourné vous et jack le premier
vidéoclip dans l'histoire de la province
[Musique]
effectivement j'étais fasciné à l'époque
par ses clips où les musiciens se
mettait en scène juste est souvent eux
mêmes puisqu'ils faisaient ça et après
c'est devenu une espèce de mode dont je
pense qu'il faisait appel à des
débrayages autorités et c'était un bar
qui s'appelait le ch claque de chez nick
et il y avait une petite ruelle à côté
qu'on appelait la ruelle new york qui va
maintenant faire partie
petit diamant alors voilà je n'en ai
toujours robert en dise ah ben moi j'ai
joué là avant toi a terminé le jargon on
dit que l'année 2010 huet est sans aucun
doute la plus occupée pour vous de
prendre longtemps
foot un peu fou là ouais ouais ouais
donc le voyage à jared australie je pars
pour berlin j'ai ensuite la corée du sud
et ensuite je vais faire le merveilleux
film d'andré forcier un peu inspiré de
la vie de en fait c'est passé pour
inspirer de la vie mais la présence du
frère marie victorin que je vais jouer
avec roy dupuis
donc cela devrait tourner sans en
juillet-août ensuite j'ai enchaîné avec
la pièce je suis mix et la joie des
petites vacances après 100 avant de
venir ici
faire la face cachée de la vie le
chômage ce n'est pas pour vous j'espère
que non yves jacques merci merci
beaucoup plus versés
[Musique]